>> Alright, Michael. So, let's write that
down in math, okay? You like math, right?
>> I do.
>> Okay. So here's the math version of it. I'm going to
just say that the utility that we receive for visiting a
sequence of states, S0, S1, S2 ellipsis, is simply the sum
of all the rewards that we will receive for visiting those states.
>> Sure.
>> Does that make sense?
>> Yeah.
>> Is that consistent with what you were
doing when you were thinking about the grid world?
>> Yeah, exactly. But I thought we were going to make that not
definitional, we were going to derive that it had to be that way.
>> No, we're not. They can read about it. It'd
take me, like, an hour and a half to do it.
>> Alright.
>> And I'm already losing my voice. But. What I do want
people, I want you to believe is that the utility of the sequence
of states, thinking of it as the sum of all the rewards, makes
sense, right? And then if nothing else, at least it makes, it's consistent
with what you've been doing as we've been talking about this grid work.
>> Yeah, absolutely. I mean it, it also kind of makes me think about money.
>> Go on.
>> Well, so, so, I mean, that's sort of how money works. If we get some kind
of payoff each day, those payoffs get added
to each other. They don't get, you know, subtracted
or multiplied or square rooted or whatever. They
just, you know, they go into your bank account,
and things add. So this feels like, kind
of like that. It's like money in my pocket.
>> Sure, if you have a big enough pocket.
Okay, I'm with you on that. Alright, so I'm going to
say that this all makes sense. It, it's really awesome
and it sort of doesn't work. And to illustrate why
this doesn't work, I'm going to give you a quiz.
>> Yay.
>> because you like quizzes.
>> So I've been told.